what injuries have you gotten and how
did you adapt
uh so obviously active lifestyle
you know growing up and
spending my life in the seal teams
ton of injuries from everything i've had
mcl tear off sprained ankles shoulders
wrists lower back elbows but the most
serious actual injury that i had um
was i had neck i had neck surgery so i
had a frame anatomy in my neck which is
they go in and they scrape
some bone away from the foramen which
hurt bad when they did it and
but it's been really good um
i was really i mean i had like lost
movement in my arm for a little while my
right arm from your neck
from my neck injury just grinding over
time and
and you know i remember there's one part
of seal training
where you're carrying these boats on
your head which is not that big of a
deal
but then the instructors would jump from
boat to boats you get these 200 pound
instructors and and they're just jumping
their boats on your head and they're
jumping from boat to boat and
it's i remember an instructor jumping
into the boat landing pretty much where
i was
and i remember hearing a grinding noise
in my neck
and i you know of course i was 19 years
old so i didn't care
bring it on but uh they don't they don't
do that anymore they actually don't jump
from boat to boat anymore which is which
is cool
they shouldn't because it's not good for
you so
but but anyways with all these injuries
whether it's mcl tear whether it's you
know high ankle sprains and
and all kinds of ligament damages in my
in my ankles and my
lower back which i've injured a few
times mo almost all muscular there uh
what i do is i do the same thing with
all of them and that is i do whatever i
can
you know if i if i when i hurt my knee
and i couldn't squat i could do like a
quarter squat
i did a quarter squats you know i'd go
out the garage and i'd stand there with
no body weight and just do quarter
squats and get the blood moving
and you know then i'd try and do my
other body parts and
you know could do pull-ups still and so
i did dead-hand pull-ups because i
couldn't even move my knee to like
kept at all so i did what i could there
you know so you can't do ring dips
do regular dips if you can't do dips do
push-ups you can't do push-ups push off
of a wall whatever it takes to
get something done you can't lift that
40-kilogram
kettlebell lift the 24 kilogram
kettlebell just do
something move get the blood in there
and not only get the blood in there
because i always think that the more
you're moving and the more you're
using that range of motion the faster
you're gonna heal
you know you're just circulating more
repairing nutrients to your body
so it would make sense to me that that's
going to help you heal
now of course you can re-damage you can
go worse you know
if it hurts to do a quarter squat and so
you do half squat
you're going backwards yeah you know so
you want to stay within the range of
motion when you're not
re-entering it or making it worse so
don't be
stupid but do
get the movement going and also i don't
know what i would do
mentally if i like couldn't do anything
at all now when i hurt my neck though i
was i was laid up i didn't think i was
gonna be i was just gonna power through
it like a tough guy yeah no i was laid
up with my
head and it just hurting and
but i'll tell you as soon as i could get
up and start trying to walk around i did
it and
like i said try to try to stay sane and
then the other thing that happens is
when you have these injuries
you know you're you got to adapt your
goals you know and you guys got to set
new goals okay
you know and and really i've never
really fully regained the strength in my
right arm
and my right pec it's not as strong as
it was
and it's definitely way weaker than my
other side you know it's probably at
70 or 80 percent okay and you know i
just have to say okay well
what can i do it's like okay you're
going to be no you're a normal human now
you know so so here's what here's here's
here's what your
new goals are and i'm you know i'm still
trying to improve
and get better at whatever it is but you
know
injuries are going to happen in life
and you got to just do the best you can
to work through them
as smartly as you possibly can and kind
of to add to the
the train smart
this may seem obvious but when you do
like higher rep like heavier weight
or not higher up sorry heavier weight um
lower reps or
real explosive stuff you're gonna be
more prone to injury so
even being just more conscious of your
movement yeah
and and really avoiding those types of
movements when you feel an injury start
to come on like if you get a little
lower back thing or a shoulder thing oh
for sure
um just be conscious of your movement
way more today i was dead lifting and i
i was like
nope okay we're done dead lifting for
the day yeah and
and you know i definitely spared myself
being laid up
you know and i just got out the roller
and just grind it out for a while got
out the ball
grounded out for a while but for sure
you got to listen you got to pay
attention
and if you feel that little twinge it's
no big deal you know
there's plenty of other ways to get your
to get your workout on
besides jack and the big steel so
yeah and you um like how you were saying
bodyweight squats you'll just do it you
know like if you're if you had a
sick squat workout planned and you feel
your lower back or
your it bend is a big one where when you
when you get after it in squats that'll
um a lot of times act up well i sprained
my ankle
sick enough probably four or five months
ago and it i couldn't do
it was weird it's one of those weird
things i couldn't do overhead squats
but i could do overhead like after a
snatch
yes i couldn't do overhead squats
because it hurt my ankle for whatever
reason yeah but i could do front squats
and regular squats
and i couldn't go to full the ones i
could still go to full depth on again i
don't know why i'm not a physician
front squats felt the best so i started
doing more and more front squats at the
time and
and then eventually you know and now i'm
back to doing everything so
figure out what you can get away with
figure out what you can do and do it
also when in regards to being conscious
of like your movement a lot of times
i know this is this is the case for me
where i'll get little injuries from just
like
racking or unracking weights just
because it's like well maybe i need to
do more functional training my friends
i don't always get injured but no it's
it's just little things you know
because that a lot of times that is like
it's unconscious i'm just put this over
here
you know and you're not meanwhile if you
do a
cleaning jerk you're like okay i'm going
to focus on this good technique
so again that goes along with being
careful of your
movement being being conscious of it
yeah especially when you feel
when you hit that fatigue when you know
you've been working out for three weeks
straight hard very little rest you're
running you know
and you start to feel these little
things come about
i think it's important to to to be
conscious of those yes
and also to what you were saying earlier
if my head's not in the game i'm not
jacking
the big weights yeah because you've got
to be thinking about it you got to be
thinking about your body position
you know before you do before before you
just try and grab on this big weight and
throw it around
yeah you got to get your head in the
game